>>> YO, WHAT'S UP, EVERYBODY?
IT'S WEEK 13 AND WE ARE BACK.
I'M FEELING GOOD.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT Y'ALL, I'M
FEELING GOOD BECAUSE WE CASHED
THE CFB PARLAY LAST NIGHT.
THE COLLEGE FOOTBALL PARLAY LAST
NIGHT.
CHAMPIONSHIP PARLAY.
I LED IT OFF.
YOU ALWAYS GIVE ME GRIPE.
I LED IT OFF, I LOST.
I'LL BE HONEST.
I LOST.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS?
WHEN YOU HAVE A TEAM, YOU KNOW,
AND SOMEBODY FALLS DOWN, GUESS
WHAT HAPPENS?
THE REST OF THE TEAM PICKS THAT
PERSON UP.
MY TEAM, NATALIE BRYSON AND
MICHAEL BOLLIN PICKED ME UP, AND
WE ALL CASHED.
SAM, YOU PUT MONEY ON IT, RIGHT?
>> HELL, YEAH.
>> RYAN, YOU PUT MONEY.
WE PUT MONEY ON IT.
WE ALL CASHED.
I'M FEELING GOOD.
HOW Y'ALL FEELING ON THIS WEEK
13?
>> AMAZING.
AND, I HAVE A SNEAKY SUSPICION
WE'LL BUILD ANOTHER -- WE'RE
PARLAY GUYS.
WE JUST HIT EVERY WEEK NOW.
I HAVE A FEELING WE'LL BUILD
ANOTHER ONE ON THIS SHOW.
>> SAM IS GETTING TO IT.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, ONCE AGAIN.
I'M GREG IVORY.
NEXT TO ME IS SAM, THE MAN, THE
MYTH, THE LEGEND, RICHMAN.
NEXT TO HIM IS OUR PRODUCER.
DROP THOSE LOCKS IN THE CHAT.
WE'LL BE GRADING THOSE PICKS AT
THE END OF THE SHOW.
RIGHT NOW -- RIGHT NOW WE NEED
YOUR HELP TO BUILD OUT ANOTHER
ANY-TIME TOUCHDOWN PARLAY
BECAUSE WE HIT LAST WEEK, RIGHT?
WE ARE ON THE UP.
WE'RE ON THE UP.
>> WE DID NOT HIP.
>> RYAN WON'T LIKE THAT.
>> WE DIDN'T HIT LAST WEEK.
BUT, YOU KNOW, IF WE ADDED
CHRISTIAN WATSON -- LISTEN, I
SAID THIS LAST WEEK.
I'M NOT AN I TOLD YOU SO GUY.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY I TOLD YOU
SO.
I THINK CHRISTIAN WATSON WAS
BROUGHT UP, I SAID IF HE SCORED,
IT WOULD BE UNBEARABLE.
>> DID YOU HIT YOUR PARLAY?
>> NO, I DIDN'T.
>> WHY ARE YOU TALKING?
>> I DIDN'T SAY TAKE MY ENTIRE
PARLAY, I SAID TAKE MY ADVICE.
THE CHAT WANTED CHRISTIAN
WATSON.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD PLAY.
HE SCORED.
>> YEAH, WHATEVER.
KENNETH WALKER SCORED TWICE.
>> YOU DON'T GET MONEY FOR HIM
SCORING TWICE.
>> GREG, DID YOU WIN YOUR
FANTASY MATCH-UP LAST WEEK?
>> OF COURSE I WON THE FANTASY
MATCH-UP LAST WEEK.
KENNETH WALKER DID ME RIGHT.
>> NOT IN THE PARLAY.
>> HE DID DO JUSTICE IN THE
PARLAY.
WASN'T IT YOUR PICK OR ONE OF
THE PICKS THAT YOU WERE PUSHING
THAT DIDN'T WIN?
>> NO, MARK ANDREWS DROPPED THE
BALL IN THE END ZONE AND KRISSEN
McCAFFREY.
YOU SAID GOD TOLD YOU CHRISTIAN
McCAFFREY WAS GOING TO SCORE.
GOD LET US DOWN LAST WEEK.
>> RYAN, THAT'S SO FUNNY.
>> I DID HAVE A DREAM, BUT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
>> THAT WAS THE BEST HANDICAP OF
ALL TIME.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT DIDN'T HIT.
>> RYAN, COME ON.
READ SOME CHAT COMMENTS.
WE HAVE TO GET THIS PARLAY
BUILT.
>> SOMEBODY DROPPED A GOOD
QUESTION THAT WE WERE ACTUALLY
TALKING ABOUT BEFORE THE SHOW.
MATT ASKED IF SAUCE IS GOING TO
SHUT DOWN JUSTIN JEFFERSON
TODAY.
>> OH.
>> THAT IS A GOOD PLACE FOR US
TO START.
>> YEAH.
>> IF PEOPLE WATCH THIS SHOW,
THEY WOULD ASSUME THAT JUSTIN
JEFFERSON WOULD BE THE FIRST LEG
OF OUR PARLAY BECAUSE GREG HAS A
THEORY THAT'S BEEN PRETTY
BULLETPROOF THAT YOU TAKE JUSTIN
JEFFERSON EVERY TIME HE'S PLUS
MONEY.
TODAY HE'S GOING AGAINST
ARGUABLY -- I THINK YOU MAKE A
FAIR CASE THAT SAUCE GARDNER IS
THE BEST CORNERBACK IN THE SPORT
RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S CRAZY TO
SAY.
THAT WILL BE AN ELECTRIC
MATCH-UP.
I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE GREG THE
FLOOR TO SEE IF HE CAN MAKE A
CASE FOR US TO TAKE JUSTIN
JEFFERSON.
I'M LEANING NO.
I DON'T WANT TO GO AGAINST
SAUCE.
>> LET'S BE HONEST HERE.
WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
WE HAVE A STRATEGY THAT WE'VE
BEEN GOING WITH THE WHOLE YEAR.
IT'S BEEN LEADING US TO THE PLUS
SIDE.
HE'S GOING AGAINST A ROOKIE.
I PERSONALLY THINK ONE-ON-ONE
NOBODY IN THIS LEAGUE CAN GUARD
JUSTIN JEFFERSON.
I WISH WE COULD SET UP A
TOURNAMENT --
>> NOBODY CAN GUARD JEFFERSON
EXCEPT THE COWBOYS DEFENSIVE
LINE.
>> THE COWBOYS DEFENSIVE LINE
WAS MADE -- MY MAN J.J. LIMITED
IN THAT GAME.
KIRK COUSINS ONLY THREW THE BALL
FOR 105 YARDS.
>> YEAH.
>> HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY TIME.
>> TRAYVON DIGGS, NOTHING TO DO
WITH THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO WITH
THAT.
LET'S -- J.J. IS PLUS MONEY.
I LIKE HIM.
I DON'T THINK HE CAN GET
GUARDED.
>> I'LL GET OUT IN FRONT OF
THIS.
I KNOW WHERE RYAN STANDS ON THIS
ISSUE AND WHERE YOU STAND.
I THINK WE NEED TO LET THE CHAT
DECIDE THAT ONE FOR US.
>> YEP.
>> IF JUSTIN JEFFERSON IS IN OR
OUT.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN RUN A
RAPID FIRE POLL OR IF THE CHAT
SHOULD SLAM IN THERE, J.J. YES
OR NO.
PUT A PIN ON THAT ONE.
LET THE CHAT DECIDE.
>> OKAY.
WE'LL LET THE CHAT DECIDE ON
THAT ONE.
I'M ALSO A PROPONENT OF ADDING
MORE JUICE TO THIS PARLAY.
CRAIG SAYS AMMAN ST. BROWN --
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> WE NEED VIBES FROM THE CHAT.
PUT IT IN THE PARLAY FOR NOW, SO
PEOPLE CAN SEE IT.
THUMBS UP IN THE CHAT IF YOU
LIKE THIS PICK, THUMBS DOWN IN
THE CHAT IF YOU DON'T LIKE THIS
PICK.
WE'LL KEEP GOING.
>> I'M LOOKING THROUGH RIGHT NOW
HIS RECENT GAMES.
10 TARGETS, 8 TARGETS, 11
TARGETS, 9 TARGETS.
HE'S GETTING A LOT OF LOOKS.
>> I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE A
TON OF POINTS IN THAT GAME.
>> ME TOO, BRO.
ME, TOO.
>> WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE.
WE HAVE TO TAKE IT.
>> ALSO, WE'RE GETTING GOOD
VIBES FROM T.B. COMEDY HE SAID
ST. BROWN IS COOKING RIGHT NOW.
I'M SEEING SOME THUMBS UP.
>> CAN I THROW OUT A BORING ONE,
UNLESS WE HAVE A GOOD SUGGESTION
FROM THE CHAT.
>> WHEN YOU SAY BORING, DO YOU
MEAN MINUS 200?
>> YEAH.
>> DERRICK HENRY IS MINUS 145.
NOT MINUS 200, BUT THAT EAGLES
RUSH DEFENSE IS A POVERTY RUSH
DEFENSE.
DERRICK HENRY IS THE ENTIRE
OFFENSE.
HE IS GOING TO WEAR THEM DOWN.
THEY'LL GET THE BALL 30 TIMES.
I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF HE
DOESN'T FIND THE END ZONE.
>> JORDAN DAVIS BACK?
DOESN'T CARE YOU?
>> NO.
THAT DEFENSE -- IT HELPS.
IT DEFINITELY HELPS.
THEY'RE STILL 25th WHEN THEY HAD
HIM.
I'M NOT TOO CONCERNED.
>> I LIKE IT.
RYAN --
>> IT WILL HIT.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> THE OFFENSE OF THE TITANS IS
DERRICK HENRY.
THEY FEED THAT MAN THE BALL AN
ABUNDANCE --
>> WHAT IS THE CHAT SAYING.
>> LET'S PLUG IT IN.
PLUG IT IN.
LET'S PUT IT IN THE PARLAY.
WE'LL ASK THE CHAT, IF THEY LIKE
IT, GIVE US THUMBS UP.
IF THEY DON'T, THUMBS DOWN.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY LIKE THE ST.
BROWN --
>> A LOT OF THUMBS UP FOR THE
SUN GOD.
WE'LL ASSUME DERRICK HENRY.
WE'LL WAIT AND SEE, BUT I'LL
PUSH THIS PROPAGANDA UNTIL WE
EMBRACE IT.
WE'RE AT TWO PICKS THIS WILL BE
A THREE-PICK PARLAY.
WE'RE CURRENTLY AT PLUS 247.
FOR THE LOVE OF GOD, SOMEBODY
DROP A PLUS 180 AT LEAST PLAY.
>> RYAN --
>> GREG, YOU HANDLE IT.
>> SAM --
>> M.J. REESE IS IN THE COMMENTS
SAYING AS AN EAGLES FAN, HENRY
IS SCORING.
>> OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT I LIKE TO HEAR.
>> YEAH.
>> I JUST LIKE -- I DON'T LOVE
THE BAD, LIKE -- RYAN, WE'RE
PARLAY GUYS.
WE BUILD THEM, WE HIT.
B/R BETTING HIT A PARLAY A MONTH
IN A ROW.
>> IT'S NOT BAD VIBES.
WE NEED TO START THINKING MORE
THIS IS THREE LEGS.
IMAGINE IF WE HIT ONE THAT WAS
12-1, 10-1.
WE WOULD BE LEGENDS.
>> I LOVE THE ASPIRATIONS.
>> I'M A BIG ASPIRATION GUY.
>> THE PEOPLE HAVE TO CHOOSE.
THE PEOPLE ARE IN THE COMMENTS
GIVING THUMBS UP TO SAM'S
DERRICK HENRY PICK.
>> OKAY.
>> YOU ARE A MAN OF THE CHAT.
>> NEXT WEEK, WE NEED A BUILD
THEM PARLAY, THEN WE'LL HAVE
RYAN'S CRAZY PARLAY.
RYAN CAN THROW TOGETHER SOME
BULLSHIT PARLAY THAT WON'T HIT.
>> LET'S DO THAT.
>> 50-1 PARLAY.
>> WE CAN MAKE A SIDE BET ON THE
SIDE THAT YOU DON'T HIT IN TWO
WEEKS.
>> OH.
OKAY.
WE WILL TALK LATER.
BUT YES.
I WOULD ABSOLUTELY TAKE THAT.
>> WE MIGHT MAKE IT THREE WEEKS.
>> NOAH GRAY AND TRENT GRAY --
>> YOU GUYS HATE TIGHT ENDS.
LET'S GET BACK TO THE CHAT.
KING SAYS GARRETT WILSON
TOUCHDOWN.
HE SCORED TWO LAST WEEK WITH
MIKE WHITE AND THE VIKINGS PASS
DEFENSE STINKS.
>> VIKINGS PASS DEFENSE MADE MAC
JONES LOOK LIKE THE FUCKING --
>> YES.
>> EXCUSE MY LANGUAGE.
>> PLUS 175.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT IT IS.
>> THIS IS WHAT I ASKED FOR.
PLUS 175
>> OKAY.
>> TELL THE CHAT I'M SORRY FOR
USING FOUL LANGUAGE.
>> WE'LL SEE IF THEY FORGIVE
YOU.
>> I'M DOWN TO PLUG IT IN AND
LET THE CHAT DECIDE.
I SEE A LOT OF A.J. BROWN FROM
THE CHAT.
>> WE ALREADY HAVE ONE FROM THAT
GAME.
>> I KNOW.
I KNOW.
THIS IS THE PEOPLES PARLAY.
>> WE NEED TO WIN TODAY, OKAY?
I'VE BEEN ON A LOSING STREAK.
WE NEED TO WIN.
>> HOLD ON.
I'M SORRY.
I SEE AN INTERESTING ONE.
I WANT YOUR TAKE.
KEENAN ALLEN PLUS 150.
RYAN, THIS IS IN YOUR TERRITORY.
>> BORDER LINE, BUT --
>> PLUS 150?
>> CHARGERS.
>> IF WE'RE GOING TO GIVE TAKES
IN THE CHAT, DROP SOME ODDS.
KEENAN ALLEN, PLUS 110.
THAT'S A FAT NO.
KEENAN ALLEN PLUS 110?
IT WOULD BE A MIRACLE IF HE
FINISHED THE GAME.
>> HE'S PLAYING THE RAIDERS.
THAT'S MONEY.
KEENAN ALLEN IS MONEY.
>> I THINK RYAN'S POINT IS FAIR.
IS HE STILL ON A SNAP COUNT?
HOW MANY TARGETS HE'LL GET.
NO DOUBT HE'S SUPER TALENTED.
MIKE WILLIAMS OUT HELPS --
>> I HAVE BETTER HAMSTRINGS THAN
KEENAN ALLEN.
>> SEVEN TARGETS IS NOT BAD.
I DON'T HATE.
>> MICHAEL BOLLIN IS SAYING
KEENAN ALLEN, BIG BOY SAYING
YES.
I DON'T KNOW, GUYS.
SPICY SPONGE, KEENAN ALLEN
LOCKED.
>> OKAY.
HOLD ON.
>> KEENAN, ST. BROWN AND DERRICK
HENRY?
WHAT WOULD THE ODDS FOR THAT BE?
LET'S VISUALIZE IT.
>> KEENAN --
>> I'M TRYING TO GET IN THE PLUS
450, 500 SWEET SPOT.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE WE HIT THAT LAST
NIGHT WHEN WE HIT THAT.
>> I'M NOT DISCOUNTING WHAT WE
DID LAST NIGHT.
WE ALL WON LAST NIGHT.
I'M HAPPY FOR US.
>> 600 IS TOO HIGH.
WE NEED TO ADD IN ANOTHER MINUS
200.
>> RYAN, WHEN YOU'RE DOING
THESE, THE PEOPLE WANT WINS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT.
THEY CARE ABOUT WINNING.
>> I'M TRYING TO GIVE A VOICE TO
EVERYONE.
>> YOU GUYS LOST, BUT YOU WENT
FOR BIG, SO, CONGRATULATIONS?
NO, THEY'LL TELL US WE SUCK AND
WE'RE THE BIGGEST LOSERS OF ALL
TIME.
WE HAVE TO WIN TO KEEP THESE
PEOPLE OFF OUR BACKS.
>> EXACTLY.
>> LISTEN, I'M TRYING TO GIVE A
VOICE TO THE CHAT HERE.
TWEET NUMBER TWO, COLE PLUS 230.
T.J. HAWKINSON, AND ANOTHER SAID
JUSTIN FIELDS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE'RE SO HUNG
UP ON KEENAN ALLEN AT PLUS 110
IF WE WERE TO TAKE KEENAN ALLEN
OUT, THIS IS A HYPOTHETICAL TO
TAKE HIM OUT AND GO TO T.J.,
WE'RE AT PLUS 846, OR TAKE HIM
OUT AND GO TO COLE OR JUSTIN
FIELDS, WHAT WOULD THAT BE?
>> RYAN, NO LIE.
YOU'RE GETTING SOME LOVE.
ONLY ONE PERSON.
THEY'RE SAYING LET RYAN COOK.
>> LOOK AT THIS.
>> I'M NOT OPPOSED TO NOT
PUTTING -- IF RYAN WANTS TO PUT
HOCKENSON IN THERE, IT'S A
WIN-WIN.
THEY EITHER HIT IT OR WE FLAME
RYAN NEXT WEEK.
>> FIRST OFF, THIS IS THE
PEOPLES PARLAY, NOT RYAN'S
PARLAY.
>> I DIDN'T SAY T.J. HOCKENSON.
THEY SAID IT.
>> OKAY.
OKAY.
LET'S ASK THE PEOPLE.
PUT IN T.J. HOCKENSON.
THERE IT IS.
THE ODDS ARE PLUS 846.
>> IF YOU GUYS LIKE THE T.J.
HOCKENSON PICK, WE NEED THUMBS
UP IN THE COMMENTS.
WE ALSO NEED THUMBS DOWN IF YOU
GUYS DO NOT LIKE THE PICK.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE PICK, PUT
KEENAN ALLEN NEXT TO THE THUMBS
DOWN SO WE SHOULD KNOW WHAT WE
SHOULD RIDE WITH.
>> THERE'S SOME GOOD COMMENTS,
HOCKENSON COULD BE THE FOCUS IF
J.J. IS KIND OF GETTING LOCKED
UP -- I DON'T HATE IT.
>> THAT'S A GOOD TAKE.
DARE I SAY A GREAT TAKE.
>> VISH PATEL LIKED HENRY, ST.
BROWN, WILSON.
IT SEEMS LIKE PICKING SOMEBODY
FROM THIS GAME.
>> THE CHAT IS KILLING.
>> RYAN, DO YOU SEE THE CHAT?
YOU ARE THE MAN OF THE CHAT.
YOU SHOULD LOOK AT THE CHAT.
>> HEY, YO.
WHAT'S WITH THE THUMBS DOWN?
ALSO, IF WE'RE GOING TO GIVE A
THUMBS DOWN, CAN WE GIVE A
THUMBS DOWN AND A
RECOMMENDATION?
IT'S THE EASIEST THING TO SAY
NO, I DON'T LIKE THAT, IT'S
HARDER TO COME WITH YOUR OWN
LOCK.
>> DO THIS -- PUT KEENAN ALLEN
BACK IN THERE.
LET'S DO THE SAME THING.
LET'S ASK THE CHAT IF THEY'RE
ROCKING WITH THAT.
>> WHAT ABOUT GARRETT WILSON?
FOR SOME REASON, WE WENT AWAY
FROM GARRETT WILSON.
>> PUT KEENAN ALLEN BACK IN
THERE, WE'LL SEE WHAT THE CHAT
SAYS.
>> EXACTLY.
EXACTLY.
WE HAVE TO GIVE RYAN HIS OWN
SEGMENT.
WE HAVE TO.
SO WE CAN SEE HOW MANY TIMES HE
LOSES HIS --
>> WIN SAID THUMBS DOWN, JAYLEN
WADDLE.
FINE.
>> LET'S GET IT.
WE HAVE KEENAN ALLEN LOCKED IN.
ODDS ARE PLUS 609.
TH
THUMBS UP IF YOU LIKE THIS,
THUMBS DOWN IF YOU'RE NOT LIKING
THIS.
>> NO, NO, NO, ALL CAPS.
JUST ONE GUY.
>> YOU KNOW ABOUT THE DELAY.
>> COME ON.
>> I WANT TO WIN, THREE THUMBS
DOWN, AARON JONES.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING ON THE
RECOMMENDATION FRONT.
M.FLIED, GARRETT WILSON.
KALE, THREE THUMBS DOWN.
GARRETT.
JUSTIN, THUMBS DOWN, WILSON.
MG 262, WILSON.
PHIL UNITE, ALLEN, FOUR THUMBS
DOWN.
>> THIS ONE IS SPLIT.
HOCKENSON WAS A FULL NO.
THIS IS SPLIT.
>> WE CAN THROW GARRETT WILSON
IN THERE, WE HAVE TO FINISH THIS
SHOW BY 1:00 P.M. EASTERN.
WE HAVE TO DECIDE SOMEONE SOON.
>> THIS IS WHAT WE'LL DECIDE.
WE'LL GO GARRETT WILSON THE
FINAL, AND THEN JUST TAKE IT.
>> AND --
>> UNLESS THEY HATE IT.
>> FINE.
>> THEN WE'LL PUT IN SOME TRAVIS
KELCE LOCK AND PISS RYAN OFF BUT
WE'LL HIT THE PARLAY.
>> GARRETT WILSON, WE GOT --
>> DO YOU WANT GARRETT WILSON OR
HIGH JUICE THING THAT'S GOING TO
BLOCK THE HIT THAT WE'LL JUST
PICK AT RANDOM.
MYSTERY BOX OR GARRETT WILSON.
THOSE ARE YOUR TWO OPTIONS.
>> THUMBS UP IF YOU LIKE GARRETT
WILSON.
THUMBS DOWN IF YOU DON'T.
WE'LL SEE HOW IT GOES.
WHAT'S THIS ONE AT?
WHAT'S THE JUICE?
>> IF WE DO AMON-RA ST. BROWN,
PLUS 100, DERRICK HENRY, MINUS
145, WE'RE AT PLUS 829.
I WOULD LIKE IT TO BE JUICIER,
BUT WE'LL SETTLE.
>> I WANT TO KNOW HOW MANY WINS
DO YOU GET MAKING YOUR PARLAYS
JUICY?
>> LIKE THIS?
>> WE HAVE TO DOCUMENT THIS.
IT HAS TO BE DOCUMENTED.
SAM KNOWS, WE WANT WINS.
YOU WANT JUICINESS.
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET RICH.
>> YOU CAN GET BOTH.
>> HOW OFTEN DO YOU GET RICH?
>> DOING STUFF LIKE THIS?
>> 30/70.
WHEN IT'S JUICED, IT MAKES UP
FOR THE 70.
>> NEXT WEEK, WE'LL GIVE RYAN
HIS OWN SEGMENT AND MAKE A SIDE
BET.
>> WE'RE LOOKING THIS IN.
EVERYBODY FEEL GOOD ABOUT THIS?
>> I WILL SAY, THE VIBES ARE
IMMACULATE IN THE CHAT.
YOU GUYS BROUGHT IT TODAY.
A LOT OF GREAT SUGGESTIONS.
GREAT VIBES.
GREAT USE OF THE THUMBS UP AND
THUMBS DOWN POLL, GREAT USE OF
THE CHAT.
>> RYAN, WE'RE LOCKING IT IN.
GIVE THE PEOPLE WHAT THE PARLAY
IS ONE MORE TIME.
>> YES, SIR.
ST. BROWN, THE SUN GOD, PLUS 100
AGAINST THE JAGUARS.
DERRICK HENRY, MINUS 145 AGAINST
THE PHILADELPHIA EAGLES.
AND THEN GARRETT WILSON AGAINST
THE VIKINGS AT PLUS 175.
YOU ADD ALL THOSE THREE UP, YOU
GET PLUS 829.
>> THERE IT IS.
THERE IT IS.
MAKE
DRAFTKINGS, IT WOULDN'T BE
SUNDAY IF I DIDN'T DO A LITTLE
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN BOOST MAGIC.
WE'RE GOING TO ALSO BOOST JAMAAL
WILLIAMS ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN FROM
MINUS 145 TO MINUS 110.
A LITTLE BOOST.
GO ON DRAFTKINGS AND FILL THAT
IN.
SAM, YOU BROUGHT US SIX BETS.
>> I DID.
>> YOU ALSO TOLD US TO SEND RYAN
BACK TO THE CHAT EARLIER IN THE
SHOW.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO RIGHT NOW.
RYAN, WE'RE GOING TO SEND YOU
BACK TO THE CHAT.
>> WAS FUN.
>> SAM, LET'S START OFF WITH
YOUR FIRST PICK.
CAN WE GET 45 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, PLEASE?
SAM, 45 SECONDS IS ABOUT TO BE
ON THE CLOCK.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'LL USE THE
WHOLE 45, WHETHER YOU USE IT OR
NOT, WE'RE ALL WAITING FOR THESE
SIX BEST BETS.
GO AHEAD.
>> ALL RIGHT.
FIRST PICK, I THINK THIS IS MY
FAVORITE PICK OF THE DAY, THE
NEW YORK JETS PLUS 3 -- THE
CLOCK HASN'T STARTED.
I GOT MORE TIME.
THE JETS PLUS 3 AGAINST THE
MINNESOTA VIKINGS.
LOOK, I JUST THINK THIS VIKINGS
TEAM IS JUST THE ULTIMATE FRAUD.
THE FRAUD OF ALL FRAUDS THEFRAU.
CLIP THAT OUT, VIKINGS ARE
FRAUDS.
YOU LOOK AT THAT PATRIOTS
OFFENSE THAT WE SAW THIS PAST
WEEK AGAINST THE BILLS, THAT
SAME OFFENSE THAT LOOKED
DREADFUL AGAINST THE BILLS,
ABSOLUTELY TORCHED THIS VIKINGS
DEFENSE.
THEY HAD 8.5 YARDS PER PLAY.
THEY SHOULD HAVE WON THAT GAME.
THE VIKINGS GOT A KICK RETURN
AND SOME QUESTIONABLE CALLS.
THAT'S WHAT THE VIKINGS HAVE
BEEN ALL YEAR.
THEY GET OUTGAINED, OUTPLAYED
AND THEY SOMEHOW WIN THESE
PLAYS.
THEY'RE RANKED 22nd, THAT'S
RIGHT AROUND WHERE THE BRONCOS
ARE, THE SAINTS ARE, SOME OF
THESE TEAMS.
IT'S NOT ELITE.
THE JETS ARE IN THE 10 SPOT, 9
SPOT.
THE JETS ARE A BETTER TEAM.
I'M GOING OVER.
THE JETS ARE GOING TO WIN THIS
GAME.
>> THERE IT IS.
MY MAN SAM JUST TOOK UP 55 OR
MAYBE 60 SECONDS TO EXPLAIN THAT
ONE.
THAT'S OKAY.
HE REALLY LIKED THIS ONE.
HE IS ROCKING WITH THE JETS PLUS
3.
LET'S BRING IN PRODUCER RYAN.
HE'S HOW WE CONNECT TO THE CHAT.
PRODUCER RYAN, WHAT IS THE CHAT
TALKING ABOUT?
NYH SAYS YES, IN ALL CAPS.
MIKE WHITE GREATER THAN ZACH
WILSON.
CHRIS SAYS ARE THESE GUYS EVER
RIGHT?
COLT CHRISTY JUMPED IN AND
RESPONDED AND SAID,
THANKSGIVING, ANY TIME TD
PARLAY, YOU CLOWN.
SHOUT OUT TO COLT CHRISTY.
>> SHOUT OUT TO THE PEOPLE WHO
PAY ATTENTION.
THE GO AHEAD.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, IF
THEY'RE PAYING ATTENTION, THEY
SHOULD KNOW THIS SHOW IS IN THE
GREEN IN WEEK 13.
>> D.J KHALED ONCE SAID YOU
EITHER WIN WITH US OR YOU WATCH
US WIN.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
WE'RE WINNING.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> WE HAVE TO GET THE PRODUCER
TO GET US OUR RECORD AND STUFF.
SO WE CAN RUB IT IN MORE.
RYAN, YOU HAVE ANYTHING FROM THE
CHAT?
IN T
IF NOT, WE'LL GO BACK TO SAM.
>> THERE'S A QUESTION FROM JAY
WHICH SAYS DVOA?
>> JUST AN ADVANCED METRIC THAT
BASICALLY EVALUATES EVERYTHING
THAT GOES INTO A PLAY, IT
EVALUATES LUCK FACTOR, STRENGTH
OF SCHEDULE, EVERYTHING ALONG
THOSE LINES.
IT'S A GOOD ADVANCED METRIC I
HAVE USED.
EVERYONE WHO LIKES THEIR OWN
STATS AND NUMBERS, BUT IT'S A
METRIC I'VE USED.
I FELT IT'S BEEN VERY PREDICTIVE
IN TERMS OF BETTING THIS LEAGUE.
LOOK IT UP.OUTSIDERS.
>> LET'S SEND RYAN BACK TO THE
CHAT.
WE ALL KNOW NOW SAM IS A BIG
DVOA GUY.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THIS NEXT PICK.
THE SECOND PICK OUT OF SIX.
SAM, ARE WE THINKING DVOA HERE?
>> MAYBE.
MY NEXT PICK, I LIKE THIS ONE A
LOT, TOO.
I DO LIKE THIS.
TITANS PLUS 4.5.
TO ME, THIS IS JUST A MATCH-UP
NIGHTMARE FOR PHILLY.
TALKED GOOD IT ON THE SHOW, THE
ONE PLACE YOU CAN BEAT PHILLY IS
ON THE GROUND.
THEIR RUSH DEFENSE IS NOT VERY
GOOD, THAT'S A PROBLEM WHEN YOU
FACE DERRICK HENRY WHO WILL GET
THE BALL 30 TIMES.
OBVIOUSLY THE BENGALS SHOT THEM
DOWN LAST WEEK RUNNING THE BALL,
IF ANYTHING, THEY WILL USE THAT
AS FUEL TO GET THE GROUND BECAME
BACK ON TRACK.
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE BALL, THE
TITANS RUSH DEFENSE IS NUMBER
ONE RUSH DEFENSE IN DVOA.
THERE YOU GO.
YOU KNOW, THAT MASTER CLASS THAT
PHILLY PUT ON THE GROUND AGAINST
GREEN BAY LAST WEEK?
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO DO THAT
AGAINST THE TITANS.
I THINK THIS IS A GAME THAT HAS
SLOWED DOWN, BALL CONTROL, I
DON'T THINK THERE'S A TON OF
POINTS.
I'M GOING OVER TODAY.
I HAVE TO DO BETTER.
>> YOU'RE GOOD.
YOU'RE GOOD.
TAKE ALL THE TIME YOU NEED.
THESE ARE LOCKS.
THIS IS QUALITY DVOA ANALYTICS
LOCKS.
WE'RE ROCKING WITH YOU, SAM.
THAT'S TWO DOWN.
TENNESSEE PLUS 4.5.
TWO DOWN, FOUR MORE TO GO.
45 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK.
TALK TO US.
>> ALL RIGHT.
NEXT PICK WE ARE TAKING
COMMANDERS MONEYLINE.
GIANTS ARE ANOTHER TEAM THAT I
THINK ARE A FRAUD.
NOT NEARLY AS GOOD AS THEIR
RECORD IS.
AGAIN, I THINK THIS IS A NICE
MATCH-UP FOR THE COMMANDERS
WHERE THEIR SPECIALTY IS IS
THEIR RUSH DEFENSE.
THEY'RE FOURTH IN RUSH DEFENSE
DVOA, THAT MATTERS WHEN THE
GIANTS WANT TO GIVE THE BALL TO
SAQUON BARKLEY.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO PUT THE BALL
IN DANIEL JONES' HANDS BUT
THEY'LL BE FORCED TO BECAUSE OF
HOW GOOD THE COMMANDERS RUSH
DEFENSE IS.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, THE
COMMANDERS ARE GETTING BETTER.
THEY MAULED THE FALCONS ON THE
GROUND.
THEY ARE GETTING TOUGHER IN THE
TRENCHES.
THERE'S SOME SORT OF HEINICKE
MAGIC WHERE THIS TEAM BELIEVES
IN HIM AND THERE'S CONFIDENCE
THERE.
THEY'RE THE BETTER TEAM AND GET
IT DONE TODAY.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN GETTING IT
DONE WITH HEINICKE AT
QUARTERBACK.
ALL HE DOES IS WIN.
HE'S BEEN WINNING FOR THEM.
CAN'T COMPLAIN.
THAT'S THREE DOWN.
THREE DOWN, THREE MORE TO GO.
CAN WE GET 45 SECONDS BACK ON
THE CLOCK.
SAM?
LET'S GET TO IT.
>> OKAY.
NEXT PICK, I'M TAKING BENGALS
PLUS 3.5.
I'VE BET AGAINST THE BENGALS A
GOOD AMOUNT ON THE SHOW.
I'M SURE PEOPLE ARE REALIZING
THAT, IF YOU PAY ATTENTION.
I'M AT THE POINT WHERE I HAVE TO
TIP MY CAP.
THIS TEAM IS REALLY GOOD.
I DO THINK THEY'RE PRETTY WELL
POSITIONED TO MAKE A STRONG RUN
HERE AT THE END OF THE SEASON.
THIS GAME IS NOT THAT BIG OF A
MISMATCH.
I LIKE GETTING 2.5 POINTS AT
HOME ON THIS SPOT.
PEOPLE WILL MAKE A HUGE DEAL
ABOUT THE REVENGE FACTOR WITH
THE CHIEFS LOSING THE AFC
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME.
I WOULD EXPECT THE BENGALS TO BE
SUPER MOTIVATED TO PROVE THEY'RE
STILL AMONG THE BEST TEAMS IN
THE AFC, THAT THEY'RE SUPER BOWL
CONTENDERS.
I THINK THEY'LL BE JUST AS FIRED
UP.
THAT HOME CROWD WILL BE
ELECTRIC.
>> THERE IT IS.
CINCINNATI PLUS 2.5.
LET'S BRING IN PRODUCER RYAN.
HE'S BEEN IN THE CHAT.
HE'S BEEN VIBING WITH THE
PEOPLE.
RYAN, ARE YOU SEEING ANY TAKES
ON MY MAN SAM'S PICKS?
>> YES, JAY SAYS LOVING BOTH
PICKS SO FAR.
HE GAVE YOU A THUMBS UP.
CHRISTIAN SAYS JETS MONEYLINE
WITH TWO LOCK EMOJIS.
DERRICK ARMSTRONG SAID PIT PLUS
1 IS THE BEST PICK ON THE BOARD.
>> I DON'T HATE THAT.
>> YEAH.
JASON SAYS HE'S DROPPING GREAT
WISDOM TODAY.
LET'S SEE.
>> I KNOW DR. 87 IS NOT HAPPY.
>> DR. 87 SAID GIANTS ARE NOT
GOOD.
>> OH.
ALL RIGHT.
I WON HIM OVER.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> DR. 87 IS IN THE COMMENTS
JUST SAYING WHATEVER IT IS
TO
TODAY.
>> HE'S ALWAYS IN THERE.
>> MAY FAIR, LOVE THE WASHINGTON
PICK.
>> RYAN, TITANS MONEYLINE, IT
WILL BE A BLOODBATH.
>> RYAN, THAT'S ENOUGH.
WHEN HE STARTS READING HIS OWN
COMMENTS, YOU KNOW RYAN IS JUST
FILLING.
SEND HIM BACK TO THE CHAT.
LET'S GO, SAM.
TWO MORE PICKS.
45 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK, PLEASE.
LET'S GO, SAM.
>> NEXT PICK, I'M TAKING RAIDERS
MONEYLINE AGAINST THE CHARGERS.
AGAIN, THIS LEAGUE IS ALL ABOUT
MATCH-UPS IN MY OPINION.
TO SAY THE CHARGERS RUSH DEFENSE
IS BAD WOULD BE THE
UNDERSTATEMENT OF THE YEAR.
THEY'RE 29th IN RUSH DEFENSE,
DVOA, ASSUMING JOSH JACOBS IS
HEALTHY, WHICH IS LOOKS LIKE
HE'LL PLAY, THEY'RE NOW GOING TO
FACE THE LEADING RUSHER IN THE
LEAGUE WHO IS COMING OFF A WEEK
WHERE HE ABSOLUTELY WRECKED
EVERYONE AND RAN FOR, LIKE, 250
YARDS.
THAT IS JUST A HUGE FAVOR IN
TERMS OF VEGAS.
I'M JUST NOT BUYING THIS
CHARGERS TEAM ANYMORE.
THEY'RE BANGED UP EVERYWHERE.
NO MIKE WILLIAMS AGAIN TODAY.
I BET AGAINST THEM LAST WEEK AND
THE CARDINALS COVERED.
THE CHARGERS WON THAT GAME.
THEIR LINE SUCKS RIGHT NOW.
THEY CAN'T STOP THE RUN.
THEY'RE A MESS.
I'M FADING THE CHARGERS AT ALL
COSTS.
>> SAM IS FADING THE CHARGERS
AND ROCKING WITH THE RAIDERS.
WE ALL KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT THE
RAIDERS.
I WAS WRONG LAST WEEK.
I WAS WRONG.
YOU TOOK THE RAIDERS LAST WEEK
OR NO?
WE DISCUSSED IT.
IF YOU DIDN'T TAKE IT, WE
DISCUSSED IT ON THE SHOW.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS I SAID
WAS THAT THE RAIDERS COULDN'T GO
TO SEATTLE AND GET A W.
HOPEFULLY THEY COME THROUGH AND
CASH THROUGH WITH THAT MONEYLINE
FOR YOU.
THAT'S FINE.
WE HAVE ONE MORE TO GO.
WE HAVE 45 SECONDS BACK ON THE
CLOCK.
THERE IT IS.
SAM, YOU HAVE ONE MORE.
TAKE IT AWAY.
>> MY FINAL PICK IS NOT TODAY,
IT'S THE MONDAY NIGHT GAME.
I'M TAKING THE SAINTS PLUS 4.
LOOK, I'M NOT GOING TO PRESEND
THE SAINTS ARE A GREAT TEAM.
TO ME, THIS IS MORE OF A FADE OF
THE BUCS WHO I THINK ARE A MESS
OFFENSIVELY.
WE BET AGAINST THEM LAST WEEK,
WE WON, BUT IT TOOK A MIRACLE.
THE BUCS MOVED THE BALL AGAINST
A BROWNS DEFENSE THAT'S BEEN ONE
OF THE WORST DEFENSES IN THE
LEAGUE.
THEY CANNOT MOVE THE BALL AT
ALL.
THEY CAN'T RUN THE BALL.
BRADY IS NOT IN SYNC.
THEY LOST ANOTHER HUGE OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN LAST WEEK.
HE'S HURT.
WINFIELD IS HURT FOR THE
DEFENSE, WHICH IS A BIG LOSS FOR
THEM.
THIS TEAM DOESN'T HAVE IT THIS
YEAR.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOOD.
GIVE ME THE FOUR POINTS.
THE SAINTS ARE SNEAKY.
THEY HAVE OWNED TOM BRADY.
I LIKE THEM AGAIN HERE.
>> THEY HAVE.
THEY HAVE.
SINCE TOM WENT TO THAT DIVISION,
THEY HAVE BEEN ON HIM.
THAT'S IT.
THAT'S SIX.
LET'S BRING PRODUCER RYAN BACK
IN HERE.
SOMEBODY IN THE COMMENTS TOLD ME
THAT THE GAME LAST WEEK WAS IN
VEGAS, THE RAIDER GAME.
THE RAIDERS/SEAHAWKS GAME.
WE CAN CONFIRM THAT GAME WAS NOT
IN VEGAS.
>> THE GAME WAS IN SEATTLE.
>> THEY JUST SAY WHATEVER IN THE
COMMENTS.
>> THEY GET AWAY WITH IT.
>> I KNOW.
NO ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE CHAT.
>> THEY DO GET AWAY WITH IT.
>> I TRY TO BE THE FACT CHECKER.
AL, VEGAS MONEYLINE MIGHT BE THE
BET OF THE DAY.
NYH, AS A CHARGERS FAN, I DO
THINK WE LOSE TODAY.
GOOD VIBES FOR YOU.
CHOP SHOP, WILL NEVER BET ON THE
RAIDERS SO INCONSISTENT.
WE ALSO HAVE FUGT SAYING BENGALS
ARE G.O.A.T.'d.
>> THEY'VE BEEN IMPRESSIVE.
>> WHAT'S IMPRESSIVE IS THAT THE
CHAT HAS BEEN 95% POSITIVE
TODAY.
>> THAT'S WEIRD.
>> THE VIBES.
>> I WOULDN'T CALL IT WEIRD.
IT'S NICE.
>> DURING THE PARLAY THEY'RE
NICE.
WHEN I GIVE MY PICKS --
>> SAM, WHEN YOU WIN, THEY'RE
NICER.
>> I LOVE THE CHAT.
I LOVE YOU GUYS.
>> RIGHT.
THEY LOVE YOU, TOO.
THEY WANTED ME TO TELL YOU THAT.
>> THE CHAT LOVES YOU, SAM.
I LOVE YOU.
I'M SURE -- I'M PRETTY SURE RYAN
LOVES YOU.
LET'S MOVE ON.
UP THERE, YOU SEE WHAT'S COMING
UP NEXT.
GREG'S PICK, AND MY MAN RYAN
WILL THROW HIS FLAVOR IN THERE,
TOO.
I WONDER IF IT WILL BE JUICY OR
NOT.
>> NO.
>> RYAN, OUR FRIENDS AT
DRAFTKINGS GOT SOMETHING
SPECIAL.
THEY GOT THE SPECIALS.
THE WEEKLY SPECIALS.
IT'S ACTUALLY THERE ON YOUR
SCREEN.
JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS TAKING ON
THE DETROIT LIONS.
WE TOUCHED ON IT EARLIER.
YOU EVEN SAID YOU THINK THIS
GAME IS GOING TO BE A
HIGH-SCORING GAME.
>> MANY POINTS.
>> WITH POINTS COMES PASSING
YARDS.
THEREFORE, WE HAVE JARED GOFF,
TREVOR LAWRENCE TO GO OVER 250
PASSING YARDS EACH.
TREVOR LAWRENCE HAS BEEN DOING
THIS FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS, LIKE IT'S NOTHING.
HE'S ALSO FACING THAT LIONS
DEFENSE.
JARED GOFF, I THINK THEY'LL HAVE
TO KEEP UP OR IT'S GOING TO BE A
LOT OF POINTS SCORED.
WITH THAT SAID, I'M LOCKING IN.
JARED GOFF OVER 250 PASSING
YARDS.
TREVOR LAWRENCE OVER 250 PASSING
IT'S A LITTLE JUICY, RYAN.
PLUS 250.
>> PLUS MONEY.
>> THOSE YOUR STANDARDS?
>> FOR A SINGLE PLAY?
SURE.
YES.
THIS IS NOT A PARLAY.
I'LL TAKE THIS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GO AHEAD.
GIVE THE PEOPLE YOUR PLAY, BRO.
>> I LIKE THAT PICK.
I LIKE THAT PICK.
>> I DO AS WELL.
>> WE'RE BREEZING PAST IT, BUT I
LIKE THAT PLAY.
>> I THINK IT WILL HIT.
MINE DOESN'T GET SIMPLER THAN
THIS.
THE CLEVELAND BROWNS HAVE NOT
SCORED MORE THAN 27 POINTS SINCE
OCTOBER.
IT IS DECEMBER NOW.
THEY HAVE A NEW QUARTERBACK
STARTING TODAY.
AND I AM FULLY AWARE THAT THE
HOUSTON TEXANS ARE NOT A GOOD
FOOTBALL TEAM.
DARE I SAY THE WORST FOOTBALL
TEAM MAYBE IN THE ENTIRE LEAGUE?
THEY WILL NOT SCORE MORE THAN 27
POINTS WITH A NEW QUARTERBACK AT
THE HELM AND A TEXANS TEAM THAT
MAY BE A LITTLE EXTRA MOTIVATED
TODAY TO PLAY AGAINST THEIR OLD
QUARTERBACK.
SO, GIVE ME THE CLEVELAND BROWNS
TEAM TOTAL UNDER 27.5 POINTS.
I THINK SOMEBODY SAID BEFORE THE
SHOW THAT I HAVE NOT LOST ONE OF
THESE BETS WHEN I GIVE IT OUT ON
THE SHOW.
I DON'T REMEMBER WHO SAID THAT.
>> MIGHT HAVE BEEN RYAN.
>> MIGHT HAVE BEEN.
MIGHT HAVE BEEN.
WE CAN'T CONFIRM.
I AM UNDEFEATED ON THE SHOW, PER
SOURCES.
CLEVELAND BROWNS TEAM TOTAL,
UNDER 27.5 POINTS.
THAT IS MY BET OF THE DAY.
>> THERE IT IS.
WE HAVE TO FACT CHECK RYAN FOR
SAYING THAT HE'S UNDEFEATED ON
THE SHOW.
>> I ENCOURAGE IT.
>> IT'S BEEN 13 WEEKS.
IT'S BEEN 13 WEEKS, YOU'RE
SAYING THAT YOU'VE NOT SPEWED
ONE LOSS ON THIS SHOW?
>> THE RYAN'S PICK SEGMENT IS
NEW.
IT'S ONLY BEEN A FEW WEEKS.
IT'S A BABY.
IT'S IN ITS INFANT STAGES.
>> WE HAVE TO BE PRECISE AND LET
THE PEOPLE KNOW WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
MY MAN IS RYAN, HE'S GETTING HIS
SEGMENT.
THIS IS RYAN'S PICK.
EVER SINCE ITS RYAN'S PICK.
WE'VE BEEN DOING IT TWO, THREE
WEEKS?
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
ABOUT THREE WEEKS.
THREE WEEKS.
3-0.
>> EMPLOYTHREE WEEKS, MY MAN WE.
WE'LL SEE IF THE RYAN PICKS
CONTINUE.
LET'S GO TO THE CHAT.
DO YOU SEE ANYTHING?
WHAT ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT?
THEY LIKE YOUR PICK?
>> CHAT LOVES MY PICK.
>> I'M SURE.
I'M SURE YOU WON'T READ NEGATIVE
COMMENTS.
>> I WOULD READ A NEGATIVE
COMMENT.
I'VE BEEN --
>> WHILE YOU'RE IN THE CHAT,
WE'RE GRADING BETS, TOO.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
WE'LL GET THERE.
I DID GET A NEGATIVE COMMENT
THAT WATSON IS BACK.
I'M CRAZY.
TIME TO GRADE SOME BETS.
JOE BOROUGH, 2 PLUS TOUCHDOWN
THE AND THE BENGALS TO WIN.
>> I LIKE IT.
I MEAN, THAT'S -- I'M NOT
BETTING THAT EXACT THING, I'M
BETTING ON THAT OUTCOME TO
PRETTY MUCH HAPPEN WITH THE
BENGALS TO PLUS 2.5.
I THINK NO MIXON, THEY'LL THROW
THE BALL MORE.
THAT WORKS FOR PASS TDs.
I'M WITH IT.
>> I LIKE IT TOO.
I'M SORRY.
I LIKE IT.
LIKE SAM SAID, THAT'S
BASICALLY -- HE'S NOT BETTING
IT, BUT THAT'S WHAT HE'S
VOUCHING FOR, WITH THE
CINCINNATI BENGALS.
I LIKE IT.
>> OKAY.
NO GREATS FROM EITHER OF YOU.
>> THAT'S AN "A" MINUS.
>> GREG?
>> "B."
>> ALL RIGHT.
THERE WE GO.
HONOR ROLL.
>> RELUCTANT B.
>> THIS IS A REVENGE COMMENT,
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU GUYS.
DR. 87 HAD THE GUTS TO JUMP IN
HERE AND GIVE A PICK.
NICK CHUBB ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN,
MINUS 170.
>> I LIKE IT.
HE'S --
>> I DO LIKE IT.
NOT AT MINUS 170.
>> MINUS 170 IS QUESTIONABLE.
BUT WE DON'T UNIT SHAME HERE.
>> IT WILL HIT.
IT WILL HIT.
TO ME, IT'S A "B."
IT'S A "B" BECAUSE IT'S PROBABLY
GOING TO HIT, BUT IT IS A LOT OF
JUICE TO LAY.
>> OKAY.
CJ, SEAHAWKS MINUS 6 1/2.
AGAINST THE RAMS.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T WANT TO BET ON ANY GAME
THAT INVOLVES THE LOS ANGELES
RAMS.
THAT'S THE WAY I WOULD LEAN.
I LIKE THAT PLAY.
>> YEAH.
I'M STAYING AWAY FROM THAT.
>> NO?
THAT'S A NO?
>> IT'S A DIVISION MATCH-UP.
>> RITTER IS COOKING DR. 87 IN
THE CHAT.
>> I SAID DR. 87, THERE WAS SOME
GUTS TO GET IN THERE.
WE'LL TRY TO GIVE HIM GOOD
VIBES.
WE'RE GETTING THERE.
SUPER BANKER MAN, JA'MARR CHASE
IN HIS RETURN TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN.
LET ME GET THOSE ODDS FOR YOU.
>> I LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW THEY'LL TRY TO FEED
HIM.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S THE THING.
WE TALK ABOUT THAT ALL THE TIME
ON THE SHOW, WHEN -- ODELL TO
THE RAMS IS LIKE THE BEST
EXAMPLE.
WHEN THEY SIGNED HIM, YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE TO BET ANY TIME TD
BECAUSE THEY'LL TRY TO GET HIM
INVOLVED.
THE BENGALS WILL DO THAT.
THEY'LL TRY TO GET CHASE FEELING
GOOD AND BACK COMFORTABLE IN HIS
FIRST GAME BACK.
>> RYAN, DID THE COMMENTER LEAVE
THE ODDS ON THAT?
>> NO, HE DID NOT.
OF COURSE NOT.
I GOT IT.
PLUS 105.
>> OKAY.
I LIKE THAT.
JA'MARR CHASE PLUS MONEY?
HE MIGHT BE IN THE SAME CATEGORY
AS JJ.
WHENEVER IT'S PLUS MONEY AND
JA'MARR CHASE, YOU TAKE IT.
>> AL MENDOZA, LAMAR >> F ME TH
G
.
>>HEY' UGH.
I WL SAY IS, I DONEAT
Y ,UT'M SEEG A COMNT
FROM BLAAZE.
PAAY WOOK  JTANDO
CKS?
INHE PARLS. FAL PIC
AZEZE JT HAN I ERE.
WE'L GHROU TA
ANNE WOINETE.
PIS ?O YOU HAV A T
I DONAVE THE , BUT
THE INY AIN.
IAN COO IT UP REA .
>>ET'S DOIT. PIS.
WHVER REY,'MOOKI AT
U YS.
JETPLUS 3, TANSLUS 5.
COMMDERS
PL 2.5.
RAIDSNEYLE.
INTSLUS4.
ANOOK BROSNDEREAM
TAL 27.
GO TO HAV OVE250.O LRENCND
IT GARTT LSONLUS 5.ATAS TARLA A?
DERRK HENR M4
.
JUY PS3,HICH TNK I A
GHERHAN I WBERE.
I THI IT SLUS 9BERE. YING
IT' HIER.
EEOPLOSE.
WEOVE WN THE PEOECHSE.
.
WEIKE.
WE'R GOIODE.
GUYSE'VE BN O
>> THAS MYDO TCK.ROW
OHNO.
>> N IAVE TO G R.H.
ONE SECO.
>>HAT'OOD BES.
YOKNOWHAT THAMEANT GOO BES.
>> YOUNOW WHA TT MEA.
E DS WLE BARNG TODA
THEOGSILLE B.
RO,OOF,OOF,ROOF
IT TE T G W SOM OF TTI
FO THE MHAT' NT TO ME,
KNOWAS TD
E LEND, HAMES SAM
HE IS OURONNEIONOOU
GUYS
WERE OU.
.
PEE..